- [sighs]
- HEY, MAN,
THIS YOUR FIRST TIME?
- OH, MAN.
I BEEN DOING ZOMBIE EXTRA WORK
ON THIS SHOW SINCE...
[chuckles]
DAY ONE, FIRST SEASON, MAN.
- MY FIRST TIME.
- OH, IT'S YOUR FIRST TIME
ON THIS SHOW?
- MY FIRST TIME
BEING EXTRA AT ALL.
- EVER?
- I'M KIND OF NERVOUS.
- OH, WOW. OKAY, MAN.
HEY, MAN, IT'S...
THAT'S ALL RIGHT.
BUT YOU'LL BE ALL RIGHT, MAN.
IT'S OKAY, MAN.
IT'S NOT THAT HARD, MAN.
YOU'LL BE ALL RIGHT.
I'M--
ME PERSONALLY, DUDE,
I'M LOOKING
FOR THAT LUNGE BUMP, THOUGH.
[chuckles]
- WHAT'S--
WHAT'S A LUNGE BUMP?
- OH, THAT'S, UH,
LIKE IF YOU, UM,
YOU GET FEATURED
IF YOU LUNGE AT SOMEBODY,
AND THEN YOU GET
A BUMP IN YOUR PAY.
AND IF YOU REALLY LUCKY, MAN,
THEY BLOW YOUR HEAD OFF.
THAT'S STRAIGHT BANK
RIGHT THERE.
- ALL RIGHT, EXTRAS.
I'M THE ASSISTANT DIRECTOR.
GATHER ROUND.
- JERRY, HEY, JERRY,
I HAD A THOUGHT, MAN,
ABOUT THE FIRST SCENE
THAT Y'ALL'S DOING--
- NOT NOW, STAN.
- STEVE, IT'S STEVE.
- OKAY.
- I NEED SOMEBODY TO LUNGE
AT THE FENCE.
- [growling]
- YOU THINK YOU CAN HANDLE IT?
- HIM?
- UH, YEAH.
- IT'S HIS FIRST DAY, THOUGH.
HE KINDA NERVOUS, MAN.
HE KINDA NERVOUS.
IT'S HIS FIRST DAY.
- OKAY, SO THE DIRECTOR'S
GONNA YELL "ACTION,"
MACK'S GONNA COME BY,
AND THEN YOU'RE JUST GONNA LUNGE
INTO THE FENCE, LIKE,
GRAAAH!
- Y-YOU WANT ME TO SAY
"GRAAAH"?
- OH, THIS IS--
- SAY WHATEVER.
- THIS IS CRAZY.
OKAY, ALL RIGHT.
COOL, MAN--
HEY, YOU KNOW--HEY.
THAT'S COOL.
HEY.
HEY, YOU KNOW I GOT
A LOT MORE EXPERIENCE, MAN.
YOU CAN JUST USE ME.
I BEEN HERE...DAY ONE.
FIRST SEASON,
SO IT--OKAY.
COOL, ALL RIGHT, THAT'S FINE.
YOU GONNA GO WITH HIM.
ALL RIGHT, GOOD FOR YOU, MAN.
GOOD FOR YOU.
- GRAAAH? GRAAAH?
- NAH, DUDE, DO--
YOU DON'T HAVE
TO SAY "GRAAAH".
DO WHATEVER THE HELL
YOU WANT TO DO, MAN.
- THAT'S THE LUNGE BUMP?
- THAT IS THE LUNGE BUMP, MAN.
YOU GOT IT.
ON YOUR FIRST DAY.
EVER BEING A EXTRA.
EVER.
YOU GOT IT, MAN.
GOOD FOR YOU.
- AND ACTION.
[eerie music]
♪ ♪
- [high-pitched voice]
AAH!
WHAT'S UP, OBAMA, MY BABY?
- WHAT THE HELL WAS THAT?
CUT.
- OH, MAN, I WOULD BE
MORE THAN HAPPY
TO FILL IN, MAN.
I'D BE MORE THAN HAPPY
TO STEP IN.
- MACK, JUST REMEMBER
WHEN YOU'RE COMING
THROUGH THE FACTORY THAT,
LIKE, YOUR MIND IS STILL
ON THE CAR OUTSIDE, ALL RIGHT?
- HEY, I MEAN,
Y'ALL GOTTA PICK PEOPLE
BASED ON QUALIFICATIONS, MAN.
- OKAY.
- HE DON'T HAVE ANY EXPERIENCE.
- IT WAS A GOOD NOTE,
GOOD NOTE.
BUT MAYBE WHAT I WAS DOING
SORT OF SUPERSEDED THAT.
- AGREED.
YEAH, WE WERE JUST...
- YEP.
- DISCUSSING THAT.
ABSOLUTELY, IT SUPERSEDES IT,
YEAH.
BUT LET'S DO ONE
THAT JUST CEDES IT, OKAY?
JUST SAME LEVEL.
WE'RE GOING AGAIN
STRAIGHT AWAY, OKAY?
- WOW, OKAY.
- RIGHT AWAY, RESET.
- HE'S NOT DOING
A GOOD JOB AT IT.
YOU'RE DOING GREAT,
THOUGH, MAN.
OPPORTUNITY KNOCKS, YOU GOTTA
ANSWER THE DOOR, MAN.
- AND ACTION.
- WAIT TILL I TELL YOU.
[growling]
[eerie music]
♪ ♪
- [high-pitched voice]
ME-ME-ME-ME, ME-ME,
ME-ME-ME-ME-ME-ME-ME!
- CUT.
- I'D BE MORE THAN HAPPY
TO STEP IN
AT ANY TIME
YOU WANT ME TO.
I'D BE MORE THAN HAPPY
TO DO IT.
- JUST A CERTAIN SENSE
OF URGENCY
IS ALL WE'RE LOOKING FOR.
CLOCK'S TICKING, YOU GOT
SURVIVORS TO FIND, RIGHT?
- CAN I TELL Y'ALL SOMETHING
FOR A SECOND?
THIS DUDE RIGHT HERE IS NOT
DOING WHAT A ZOMBIE DOES.
THIS DUDE WAS LITERALLY
ON OUR LAST TAKE
WAVING HIS HAND UP IN THE AIR
LIKE THIS, JERRY,
MAKING BEEKER SOUNDS.
HE SOUNDED LIKE BEEKER
FROM THE MUPPETS, Y'ALL.
- THANK YOU, THAT'S GREAT.
JUST A TICKING CLOCK ON THIS
IS ALL WE'RE LOOKING FOR,
BECAUSE THERE ARE SURVIVORS,
IS WHAT WE'RE AFTER.
- OKAY.
- OH, JEEZ.
- BUT I FELT AMBIVALENCE
IN THERE.
- THE AMBIVALENCE IS ART.
IT'S GORGEOUS, AND WE LOVE IT.
BUT THERE ARE ZOMBIES, SO IF WE
COULD JUST PICK UP THE PACE,
JUST A HAIR, THAT'D BE GREAT.
STRAIGHT AWAY, PLEASE.
RIGHT AWAY.
- ALL RIGHT, GOING AGAIN.
- JERRY, BUT JERRY,
WE'RE NOT DOING
"NIGHT OF THE LIVING MUPPETS,"
ARE WE?
- WE ARE NOT.
- 'CAUSE THE BEEKER
IS NOT A ZOMBIE.
- DO YOU HAVE ANY NOTES?
- YEAH, DON'T BE
A [bleep]ING BEEKER.
- QUIET, PLEASE.
- ACTION.
[eerie music]
- [high-pitched voice]
I'M GONNA EAT YOUR BRAIN!
ZOMBIE.
- CUT.
- NO!
HE ACTUALLY JUST SAID
THE WORD "ZOMBIE"!
COME ON, MAN!
Y'ALL EVER HEAR OF A ZOMBIE
SAYING THE WORD "ZOMBIE" BEFORE?
NO, YOU HAVEN'T.
I DON'T THINK SO.
- YOU KNOW WHAT?
GET RID OF THIS GUY.
- THANK YOU!
THAT'S WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT.
DUDE, I'M SORRY, DOG,
BUT YOU TERRIBLE AT THIS, MAN.
- HIM.
- HEY, MAN, NO.
HE TALKING ABOUT HIM.
HE'S TALKING ABOUT HIM,
'CAUSE HE SAID "ZOMBIE".
- THANK YOU, STEVE.
- BECAUSE--NO.
NO, YOU WANT ME TO LEAVE?
HEY, MAN, I BEEN UP HERE
STAGGERING AROUND HERE
FOR 3 1/2 YEARS,
AND I BEEN STARTLING EXTRAS
LEFT AND RIGHT.
WHEN DO I GET
TO STARTLE THE LEAD, HUH?
- ONE MORE FOR SAFETY.
STRAIGHT AWAY, HERE WE GO.
- STILL ROLLING.
- ACTION.
[eerie music]
- HEY, WHAT DO WE DO
IF WE HAVE TO GO
TO THE BATHROOM?
- WE LIKE IT?
- I LOVE IT. GENIUS. MOVING ON.
- I GOT IT.